music over this trailer is Pink Floyd's
time from Dark Side of the Moon a song
that also opened Marvel's eternals it's
one of my favorite classic rock tracks
and I always love hearing it and while
the lyrics totally apply to what Barry's
going through thematically kicking
around on a piece of ground in your
hometown feeling like time has passed by
I've never really felt like tonally the
Rock chords of the song have matched any
of these superhero films maybe it's just
because for me the music on its own
creates a cinematic image in one's head
it kind of feels like it just sort of
cheapens the song to make it the
soundtrack needle drop but I guess as I
get older I just kind of feel that way
about most rock songs that are used in
movies like leave radiohead's creep out
of Guardians volume 3. I realize I'm now
an old man yelling at clouds or maybe
I'm just a speaker in Pink Floyd's time
but whatever I do love hearing the song
and I will say it's really cool how this
trailer sinks the editing to kicking
around on a piece of ground with Kara
stomping and kicking Zod
oh
[Music]